-And, finally, guys,
it's time to take a look at
the stories
making headlines today
and weigh the good with the bad.
It's time for "Pros and Cons."
Here we go.
-♪ Pros and cons
and pros and cons and
pros ♪
-Nice to see you back, Tariq.
I'm glad everything cooled down.
-Whatever.
-Guys, tonight,
we'll be taking a look at
the pros and cons
of sending nudes to space.
NASA's working on a mission to
send nude photos of human beings
into space with
hopes of attracting aliens.
-Oh.
-No one knows if
this will actually work,
so let's take a look at the
pros and cons of
sending nudes to space.
Here we go. Pro...
Con...
-Hey!
-Pro...
Con...
-Hey!
-What is that thing?
What is that thing? Oh, man.
Pro...
Con...
And, finally, pro...
That's our "Pros and Cons,"
everybody.